comme beaucoup nous croyons tous au père
noël surtout ce soir y est en tout cas
un petit garçon qui lui n'a jamais cessé
de croire au père noël et comme chaque
année jean pierre des corps sa maison de
mille lumières pour attendre celui qui
passera à minuit cela se passe un an
soit sur ornain dans la neige depuis
quelques temps à la tombée de la nuit du
côté de n'en soit sur ornain il se passe
quelque chose au ralenti pour s'arrête
pour mieux regarder fait tout est donc
je réfléchis beaucoup la nuit et où et
comment je vais pouvoir faire ça ça si
je vais avoir assez de matériel pour
morlaàs pour le plaisir d'avoir ça
tornos donc maintenant maintenant que
j'ai plus grand chose à faire je pense
beaucoup aux enfants pour ça que j'aime
bien créer des trucs et enfants sont
toujours heureux quand ce genre que
j'aime chez le chat gris même important
pour lui qu'il ait cette activité là et
qu'il est ses petits enfants autour de
lui parce que je crois que sinon ils
seraient pas comme il est quoi
actuellement on veut je pense dire qu'on
a la chance d'avoir un papa très jeune
et qui reste aussi jeunes de mentalité
tous les jours de la semaine depuis deux
ans jean pierre travaille d'arrache-pied
à 56 ans il est retraité
il fait tout lui-même en passant par
tous les métiers avec l'aide de ses
filles passent à l'heure
plus de cent mille petites lampes des
kilomètres de fils électriques et d'un
coup de baguette magique
toute la façade de la maison revêt son
habit de lumière
c'est l'histoire de noël et de l'arche
de noé les enfants est-ce qu'ils ont là
c'est des rêves quand ils viennent les
styles y rêve vraiment noël
je vais voulu bien faire pour ça mais
j'essaierai toujours faire encore mieux
il aime travailler plein de choses sur
les volets de tueurs
un spectacle éblouissant et l'on vient
nombreux admirer ce travail étonnant
dire que tout ça a été réalisé avec des
matériaux de récupération
l'an prochain jean-pierre se propose de
reconstituer son village à échelle
réduite et tout en lumières bien sûr on
pourra même s'y promener et qui se
rencontrent et peut-être le père noël